I think we were like the normal young
married couple we didn't really fight
about money but they wouldn't talk about
money it was really hard to go from
having controlled all your money to
sharing it with someone else we've been
married for five years and have one
daughter who was born right in the
middle the debt snowball are you doing
if you look up in the doggie yeah how
much dad have you paid off it was a
little over a hundred and forty thousand
dollars but we are here to celebrate
really the last one hundred and twenty
five of that because we did that in
about 30 months and when people ask you
how did you do that what are the secrets
to getting out of that I remember when
we were house hunting we were looking
for houses and I was trying to figure
out how much we could afford per month
and how much our payment was going to be
I was trying to ask her will cabl what
are your monthly payments you know these
are what mine are to see how much we'd
have left after we combined our income
and I remember when she told me you know
well this is my student loan payment I
just was like what do you have how much
in student loan debt before we didn't
talk about it I think on my end there
was a lot of guilt because I came into
the marriage with the student loan debts
like he had a car payment but compared
to the student loan debt it was nothing
so you know I never wanted to bring it
up because I felt guilty like this was
my problem to fix and as I talked to him
about it like it's not his problem we
didn't talk about money that first year
we married because I think that we kind
of both knew that if we did like it
would lead to a fight you know so we
just it was better to just brush it
under the rug and just not think about
it whenever dad came to us and said like
he was going to do the financial peace
class at our church and he'd like us to
go through it with them I think both of
us were like okay we don't need to do
that we're fine we're not having any
issues it wasn't so much I didn't think
we needed it I just didn't want to
uncover all the nasty beasts in our
closet because I knew would force us to
address these issues in my mind I looked
at is something we'll never pay off you
know there's no way this works for
people with thirty forty thousand
dollars in that not 130 the written
budget is absolutely everything because
when we weren't doing the written budget
and giving every dollar a name we
weren't making any progress our money
was just escaping away from us but once
you assigned a adult a name to every
dollar that's when you really start to
make the progress we went through the
class in the spring 2012 and then that
next winter we got art all of our tax
return information I'll never forget my
jaw hit the floor when I opened that
envelope and said we had paid like
twelve thousand dollars interest in one
year and I'm thinking we don't make
enough money to be giving someone twelve
thousand dollars a year like this is
insanity it was kind of at that moment
for me that I looked down I said wow you
know we've got to do something about
this and that's that's when we really
really started to bear down on the
budget and attack this thing with a
vengeance
and then kind of like presented it to me
like if we just buckle down and we do
this the opportunities to do all of
these things open up and so I think that
was the turning point for me mess it up
a lot of shifts as a nurse did yeah a
lot of extra hours a lot of long 12-hour
shifts a lot of time away from my family
but it's worth it because now it's done
every little thing we could find I mean
an extra 20 bucks here and there you
know just everything went straight to
the loan we settled our couch our
kitchen table like pretty much if we
figured we could live without it we sold
it yeah I mean we sold everything in the
house that wasn't nailed down and I was
like okay we've got to get one big last
you know injection into this debt
snowball and so that's when I actually
talked to her the first time about
selling my truck when you sell that nice
truck and move into that 1900 hour car
that right there I'll get you going yeah
that opened some eyes that's I think
that really told people when these guys
are serious we had run the numbers and
it was well within our means to keep it
I thought oh and oh you know we're fine
we don't need sell the truck out of the
truck and then it just kept weighing on
my heart and weighing on my heart and I
kept kind of hearing God tell me like
you need to sell the truck you need to
sell the truck
we just we sold it we got rid of it we
got a really good price for it we just
took all that money I set aside like two
grand so okay I'll buy myself a new car
with this and then the rest of it you
know
Wham we made a big day and that was just
it was just all downhill from there now
that we're debt-free and we look back
you know it's kind of hard to believe
and now we can start saving that money
and investing it for our future and for
our daughter's future and from here on
out like our kids are going to grow up
not ever having to worry about life 3 2
1 we're damn free